[Müzik]
üzerine çalışan bir insan olarak bana en
çok sorulan soru mükemmel bir ilişkiyi
bize tarif edebilir misiniz
şimdi bu teriks konuşmasının hatrına
size mükemmel eski tarifiyle geldim
başlıyorum anlatmaya Bu hikayede
Öncelikle sizi 30 sene öncesine
götürüyorum 30 sene önce Karşıyaka'nın
İzmir Karşıyaka'nın sokaklarında
birbirlerinden hiç habersiz yürüyen iki
çocuğun hikayesinden bahsetmek istiyorum
size İkisi de daha 4 sınıftalar
hastaneye gidiyorlar birbirlerinden hiç
haberleri yok aynı sınıftalar hatta bir
dönem ama birbirleriyle iletişim
kurmuyorlar Yani daha 9 yaşındalar zaten
iki sene sonra aynı sokağa taşınıyorlar
böyle birbirlerinden birkaç farklı
apartmanda oturuyorlar farklı arkadaş
gruplarıyla oynuyorlar sokakta ama
Birbirlerine yakın değiller
birbirleriyle hala tanışmıyorlar
yine 2-3 sene sonra bir Dershane
sınavında yan yana oturuyorlar böyle
birbirlerine şöyle bir bakıyorlar Ama
yine bir alakaları yok 2001 yılında
İstanbul'a taşınıyorlar alakasız biri
bir üniversiteye de yine diğer
üniversiteye gidiyor Hatta zamanın
birinde İstiklal Caddesi'nde Yolları
kesişiyor teğet geçiyor biri vitrine
bakarken diğeri arkadan kız arkadaşıyla
yürüyor geçiyor
bu iki insanın
zamanı 2006 yılında
Yıldızlar bir araya geldiğinde ve doğru
noktaya geldiğinde kesişiyor
birbirlerine bakıyorlar o anda deliler
gibi aşık oluyorlar
çok güzel bir hikaye değil mi
Bu Bizim Hikayemiz
sevgili eşim Bugün de burada aramızda
sevgili eşimle tanışma Hikayemiz Ve
tabii ki 16 yıldır birlikte bu mükemmel
ilişki 5 buçuk yaşındaki kızımızla daha
da güzelleşti
Şimdi ben eşimle
[Müzik]
O da burada
[Alkış]
Şimdi biz eşimle o müthiş bakışma anında
Hani yıldızların kavuştuğu bakışma
anında dedim ki Tamam ben Ruh eşimi
buldum yani daha olabilir mi Sizce bu
kadar tesadüf bu kadar benzerlik
ortaklık bir sürü ortak arkadaş her
şeyimiz aynı inanılmaz
yani düşünüyorum artık ruh eşimle
kavuştuğuma göre
biz hiç konuşmadan anlaşacağız her an
birlikte olacağız bütün İhtiyaçlarımı
Benim Bundan sonra o karşılayacak doğal
olarak hiç tartışmayacağız tartışacak ne
olabilir ki insan ruh eşiyle niye
tartışsın çok saçma
Üstelik de böyle bir ortak Gelecek
hayali içerisinde muhteşem bir şekilde
yol alacağız şimdi bu değil mi zaten
bize mükemmel ilişki olarak öğretilen
şey şöyle bir bakalım hadi birlikte
şimdi mükemmel ilişkiyi içerisinde Biz
diyoruz ki oraya işimize bir gün
buluşacağımızda konuşmadan
ihtiyaçlarımızı aktarmadan
anlaşabileceğimizi bütün ihtiyaçlarımızı
birbirimizin karşılayacağız tartış
anlamsız ve kötü olduğunu O yüzden de
mümkün
olduğu dikkatmasın Ali Rıza Bey modunu
takımımız gerektiğini
gelecek bir tane gelecek hayaline tek
başımıza ilerleyeceğimize inanıyoruz
güzel bir hayal
anlatıyorum yani burada böyle övünmek
için işte ben Ruh eşimi buldum sizin
haliniz varsa görün gibi bir yerden
anlatmıyorum Tabii ki çünkü yani
düşününce Hani hepimiz bu hayallerle
büyütüyoruz yani
kitaplar masallar işte ne bileyim sağdan
soldan duyduklarımız bize bunu söylüyor
Eğer ruh eşimiz gelecek ve her şey
yoluna girecek çok güzel olurdu Öyle
olsa öyle değil mi
doğrusu şu ki böyle bir şey yok tabii ki
Arkadaşlar biz eşimle Ee bu yıldızların
çakıştığı günün hemen ertesi günü dışarı
çıktığımız zaman ilk ben ona elimi
uzattım son derece spontan ve doğal bir
şekilde elimi tutacak Çünkü şöyle
baktığımda
saçma ama elimde tutuşarak mı
yürüyeceğiz Neyse çok saçma dedi Allah
dedim ne diyor bu benim ruh eşim Şimdi
elimi tutmuyor adam
sonra birkaç gün geçti ben ona dedim ki
ya ben orman yürüyüşlerin çok severim
Deniz kenarında böyle uzun uzun keyif
yapmayı Aydede beni hiç hoşlanmam
sonra
sen ben onu bir yerlere davet ettikçe
aktivitelere Şunlara bunları bazılarına
Tabii ki Katılıyor dışında abartmayayım
ama
Ben çıkışında gelirim diyor Biz her şeyi
birlikte yapacaktık
ilk Konuşmadan beni anlamıyor her şeyi
de söylemem gerekiyor falan ya böyle
Sonra baktım irili ufaklı küçük büyük
bir sürü konuda kavga ediyoruz sen
bayağı bildiğiniz tartışıyoruz Biraz
sonra adeta anlatacağım
Üstelik bir de ya son darbeyi
hayallerimizi farklılığı vurdu tam yani
Eninde sonunda benzer hayalleri
istiyorduk ama gidiş Yolumuz çok
farklıydı
hayatta gidiş yolundan puan vermiyordu
arkadaşlar ne yapacağız Ben dedim kendi
kendimi Demek ki ruh eşim Bu değilmiş
benim Yol yakınken geri mi dönsem
ama bir yandan da bakıyorum çok seviyor
beni Ben de onu çok seviyorum Bütün
İhtiyaçlarımı dinliyor
farklılıklarımıza karşı çok saygılı
gözümün içine bakıyor benimle ortak
Hayaller kurmaya çalışıyor filan yani
dedim bir şans mı versem acaba
şimdi bunları anlatma sebebim şu eminim
aramızda ruh eşini arayan veya
tartışmaların kötü olduğuna inanan ya da
o kişiyi bulduğunda Hani o Destinasyon
varış noktasında o muhteşem insanı
bulduğunda her şeyin çok akışkan ve
güzel ilerleyeceğine inananlarımız var
Ben de öyleydim Çünkü mükemmel ilişki
beklentim bunlardı
o zamanlarda Ben ilişki bilimi üzere
çalışmaya başladım tam güzel denk geldi
baktım Çünkü beklentilerimle gerçek hiç
örtüşmüyor nasıl olabilir
onu deneyim hem de eğitimimle
öğrendiklerimden bir ilişkiyi yeniden
tanımlama
iyi anlatmak istedim Şimdi ruh eşi
kavramı iyi güzel hoş ama çalışmalar
şunu gösteriyor Ruhi kavramına
inandığımız zaman biz Aslında
ilişkilerimiz için daha az yemek
harcıyoruz Çünkü şöyle diyoruz zaten bu
insan benim için yaratılmışsa zaten o
benim ruh eşimse Ben ne yaparsam yapayım
Zaten yanımda kalacak giderse de döner
Çünkü birbirimiz için numarası değil mi
Yani ben Ondan başkası bana değil benden
var E o zaman niye uğraşayım zaten öyle
benzerlikler çok güzel benzerlikler
hakikaten önemli mesela ortak şehrimiz
İzmir ya da ortak eğitimlerimiz diğer
bütün benzerliklerimiz bizim ilişkimizi
uzun ömürlü kılan faktörler arasında ama
ruh eşi kavramı diye bir şey yok Üzgünüm
hayallerinizi yıktığım için ikincisi
konuşmadan anlaşmak meselesi maalesef
henüz konuşmadan zihnimizi okumayı icat
edemediler çok isterim Şimdi size şunu
anlatmak istiyorum Eğer denk geliri de
bir gün benim ofisime evime gelseniz
görürsünüz ki her taraf bitki her taraf
çiçek ben çok seviyorum hobim benim
ama Sevgili kocam bir türlü idrak
edemedi bunu buna Hediye alacak her
seferinde bekliyorum bitki gelecek diye
gelmiyor 1 3 5
zihnimi okumuyor Belli ki
sana dedim ki tatlım aslında bana bitki
hediye edebilirsin biliyor musun Sana
ben çok seviyorum ya şöyle bir baksan
gördü ondan sonra bana bitki almaya
başladı Peki şimdi ben küseyim mi şey mi
diyeyim ben söyledim diye alıyor
Tabii ki öyle değil ben söyledim diye
alıyorsa o aslında çok güzel bir şey bu
şunu gösteriyor demek ki beni dinliyor
bu adam benim İhtiyaçlarımı önem veriyor
Benim ihtiyaç karşılamak için uğraşıyor
ya da birbirimizin ilk ayda getirdiğimiz
zaman
ben özlemden ayılıp bayılıyorum böyle
547 tane mesaj atmak istiyorum kendisini
bu cevap alamıyorum atıyorum da cevap
gelmiyor en sonunda gelmesinden kuru
kuru bir bakın bir mesaj geldi
tatlım biz akşam yemeğine oturduk Umarım
senin güzel Günün güzel geçmiştir İyi
geceler
Özlem Hani ölüyordum ben burada
Şimdi ben hiç
Bunlar razı da olabilirim Ama buna razı
olmak benim ihtiyaçlarım benim
beklentilerimi karşılamıyor O zaman ne
yapmalı baz mı geçmeli tamamen Hayır
oturduk ve neye ihtiyacımız olduğunu
konuştuk Benim beklentilerim %100
karşılanmıyor olabilir ama ortak bir
noktada buluşunca İkimiz de kendimizi
duyulmuş hissettik ve bu aslında
önemliydi bizim için bu Çünkü o
dinamikte ben de varım O da var
sonra Birbirimizin her şeyi olmak E ben
orman yürüyüşünü onunla yapamıyorum
tiyatroya gitmek istiyorum gelmiyor Ne
yapacağım ben bunlardan vaz mı geçeyim
Hayır ben kendi isteklerimi çok sevdiğim
insanlarla yürütürken O da çok sevdiği
Formula bir yarışlarını başkalarıyla
izliyor şimdi E bu bizi kötü bir çift mi
yapıyor Hiç de değil ikimiz
ihtiyaçlarımızı ayrı ayrı bu tarz
ihtiyaçlarımızı ayrı ayrı karşıladığımız
zaman birbirimize çok daha mutlu çok
daha Doymuş çok daha birbirimize dönük
bir şekilde dönebiliyoruz Birbirimizin
her şeyi
olamayacağımızı kabul ettik ve bununla
ilgili bir rahatsızlık duymuyoruz Çünkü
çok şöyle bir yanılgı var ilişkinin
içerisine girdiğim zaman gizemden geriye
bir şey kalmaz
Siz artık böyle bir şey olduğunda ben
kendi bireyselliğimi tamamen yitiriyorum
Aslında en güzeli benim o ilişkinin
içerisinde hala Gizem olarak kalabilmem
aynı şey işim için de geçerli Tabii ki
birey olarak da o ilişkinin Tesla mutlu
olabilmek Peki ya tartışmamak
en büyük tartışmalarımızdan bir tanesini
çilek reçeli üzerine yaptık
insanlar çilek reçeli Üzerine niye
tartışıyor diyorsanız biz bulduk onu da
yolunu bulduk sonra bir baktık ki
aslında çilek reçeli diye başladığımız
tartışma Meğer birbirimizin Şefkat
ihtiyacı ile ilgiliymiş yani tartışmalar
kötüdür diyenlere lütfen aldırmayın
tartışmalar Biz ancak konuları kötü
yönetirsek kötüdür Aslında tartışmalar
bizim ilişkideki sıkıntıları kendi
içimizdeki huzursuzlukları bilimsel
deyişle acı noktalarına birbirimize
aktarma şeklimizdir eğer orada
Birbirimize doğru şekilde kulak verirsek
birbirimizi iyi dinlersek birbirimize
hakaret etmeden birbirimize hor görmeden
birbirimize kötü davranmadan
Tartışmalara yürütebilirsek tartışmalar
en iyi öğrenme deneyimleridir ilişkileri
için Üstelik de bir küçük tüyo daha
vermek istiyorum burada tartışmadan
sonraki telafi davranışları yani orada
Sonuçta bir gerginlik yaşadık Ama bunun
sonrası var o telafi davranışları
ilişkiye muhteşem bir iyilik katıyor
aslında Çünkü araştırmalar şunu
gösteriyor ilişkiler negatif
etkileşimlerin fazlalığından dolayı
bitmiyor pozitif etkileşimlerin
azlığından dolayı bitiyor Yani çok
tartışıyoruz diye ayrılmıyoruz ben artık
Sevildiğimi hissetmiyorum Ben artık
saygı gördüğümü hissetmiyorum diye
ayrılıyoruz ilişkilerden O yüzden
tartışıyorsak da sonrasında telafi
edebiliyorsak zaten Tartışmalara da
saygısızca yapmıyorsak İşte o zaman bu
bizi güzel bir ilişkinin içerisinde
tutuyor
gelelim Gelecek hayali meselesini
bireysel hayalleri var Ve tabii ki bu
hayalleri ortaklaştırabilmek çok önemli
ama hayalleri ortaklaştıracağız derken
benden Ve karşımdaki insandan çaldığımda
benden ve ondan geriye bir şey
kalmayabiliyor burada iki insanın ortak
bir hayal içerisinde kendi hayallerini
eritebilmesi eritmek derken öğütmek
değil yani ona dahil edebilmesi Aslında
en güzeli Yani kim insandı birbirinin
kanatlarının altındaki Rüzgar olması
birbirine uçurması birbirinin olabilsek
en iyi haline getirmesini önemsiyoruz
öyle olduğu zaman Çünkü iki insanda Hem
mutlu oluyor hem de iyi ki ben bu
ilişkideyim bu ilişki Beni daha iyi bir
versiyonuma götürüyor diye düşünebiliyor
Ben mesela
zaman zaman Eşimin üzerine türlü
fikirler atıyorum
en son uygulama fikrimizi attım üstüne
dedim ki aşkım benim böyle bir fikrim
var baktı böyle meyvesi yazılım
öğreneyim dedi Çünkü neden olmasın şu
anda uygulamamızın yazılımcısı Ve
yöneticisi kendisi oldu kendisinde büyük
hayali de yazılım öğrenmek gördüğünüz
gibi iki farklı hayali bir potada
erittik İkimiz de hayallerinize kavuştuk
yani yapabilince yapabiliyoruz diye
düşünmek istiyorum
şimdi peki ben size bunları anlattım
Şimdi desem ki Arkadaşlar ben mükemmel
bir ilişki içerisinde mıyım artık
Cevabınızı Bence hayır olmalı değil mi
Çünkü aslında deminden beri anlatmaya
çalıştığım mükemmel ilişki tarifini
artık değiştirip sağlıklı ilişkinin
tarifini vermek istiyorum size ve
diyorum ki ruh eşi diye bir kavrama
inanmak bize oldukça kötü etkiliyor
ihtiyaçlarımızı açıkça aktardığımız
zaman onların karşılanmaları mümkün
oluyor
ama zor durumda değiliz
sağlıklı tartışmalar Aslında ilişkinin
ileriye gitmesini sağlıyor ve bireysel
hayallerine desteklendiği ortak
hayallerinde kurulabildiği ilişkiler
mümkün
Şimdi ben mükemmel bir ilişki içerisinde
değilim Çünkü aslında sağlıklı bir
ilişkinin içerisinde olmak bu anlattığım
tarifin çözümü her gün gerçekten her gün
bu ilişki için aktif bir taba
harcamaktan geçiyor Ben her gün bu
ilişki içerisinde kalmanın ve bu ilişki
içerisinde iyi bir partner olmanın
kararını veriyorum ve bunun için çaba
harcıyorum ve bu çabanın karşılığını
aldığım zaman Karşındaki insan da o
çabayı bana verdiği zaman biz o ilişkide
kendimizi iyi ve mutlu hissediyoruz
Hazan düşüyoruz Hazan kalkıyoruz Tabii
ki hatalar yapıyoruz bugün anlattığım
yapmalıyız dediğim şeyleri yapamadığımız
çok oluyor ama beraber öğreniyoruz ve bu
sayede birbirimize yol arkadaşlığı
yapıyoruz küçük prenslere söylendiği
gibi oradan size bir şey alayım
söyleyeyim güle verdiğin emektir onu
değerli kılan hepinize teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]